Jon Stewart's latest impassioned plea to
help 911 first responders sickened by
the attack is giving the issue new
urgency in Washington dozens of police
firefighters and others joined Stewart
at an emotional Capitol Hill hearing
yesterday the former Daily Show host
blasted Congress for allowing a fund
that was set up to pay for their health
care to run short of money behind me a
filled room of 911 first responders and
in front of me a nearly empty Congress
your indifference costs these men and
women their most valuable commodity time
so one thing they're running out of this
should be flipped this hearing should be
flipped these men and women should be up
on that stage and Congress should be
down here answering their questions as
to why this is so damn hard and takes so
damn long they did their jobs with
courage grace tenacity humility 18 years
later do yours Thank You Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill Nancy this issue has
been very important to John Stewart it
has and he and many others fear that
these first responders are being
forgotten that the country and Congress
have moved on after 18 years they have
seen this funding get held up before for
political reasons and they worry that
it's going to happen again you know
Congress actually allotted seven point
four billion dollars to this 9/11
Victims Compensation Fund back in 2015
and it was supposed to last through 2020
but there have been so many claims for
more than 22,000 people who got sick
after serving at Ground Zero that the
money has almost run out and earlier
this year payouts started getting
slashed in half many lawmakers were
simply unaware of that and so Stewart
was clearly looking to redirect
attention to this issue and to the fact
that there is a bill that members could
act on that would actually extend this
funding for 70 years Anthony do we know
when Congress might actually act on that
legislation Nancy well Democrat Jerry
Nadler who chairs the Judiciary
Committee says that the committee is
actually going to vote on this extension
today and there is a lot of reason for
optimism for these first responders
because there's a lot of bipartisan
support this time around even from
fiscal conservatives who had balked at
the price tag in the past so it looks
like a measure will pass
at some point but as you know who
Anthony Congress doesn't always move in
a very expeditious manner no it does not
Nancy thank you very much